you write your own music and that's like
a serious thing for you what is your
technique for writing do you or even if
you're gonna write comedy do you have to
go off into it like a quiet room or I
like I just like to be alone a lot of
time like I'll just go to like I mean
I'll go to like I'm with I drove up to
Big Sur like the other day and like it
just like by myself and just kind of
went there and like walked around that's
a beautiful kind of desolate and
beautiful beautiful is gorgeous like I
was just by myself it was nice I like I
ran into the coyote and it was like did
you really run into a coyote yeah it was
really weird we had like a stand-up like
it was like we were going in opposite
directions and like I was like I was
like this is kind of moment I was like
wow coyote he's like wow and it's like
we're pretty close but I was like wow
nature and then I was like kept going
and then he was like wait I eat you and
then I kind of followed me and I was
like oh no like I was like this this is
really so it's really really happened I
was like kind of been having a lot of
problems with like raccoons and coyotes
like you think the words out in the
animal kingdom like don't mess with this
dude so wait so did you do you have an
expert did you do you know anything
about coyotes or and I think that coyote
was really trying to just stalk you or I
heard somebody told me I don't know if
it's true somebody told me that like
coyotes will like impacts like send like
the female coyote out to Laura like play
with them and bring them maybe what they
do is they lure they like to lure dogs
they get the female coyote to go out and
like lure dog or lured dogs yeah didn't
know like and then the pack attacks the
dog yeah and I told like I was talking
about it cuz this happened to me and I
told my brother and I was like yeah they
lure them and he was like that can't be
true for humans because he's like his
thinking was like I don't want to have
sex with a coyote I would never I would
never follow a female coyote into like
but I was like but you don't you don't
know yeah you know you really don't know
like it was like you don't know you
don't know
that moment you might be like Mowgli
edge it might be like why is this coyote
playing with me like I'm gonna see what
this goes like anything you might it
because like you'd feel like you might
kind of see it yeah okay